la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
de la commission qui a demandé ce débat
je donne donc la parole au président la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées
monsieur christian cambon monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
d'abord vous remercier monsieur le
président d'avoir accepté l'organisation
de ce débat le sénat j'en suis convaincu
sonore de ce moment de vie parlementaire
et démocratique il est exceptionnel
aussi bien par sa forme avec une
expression réservée aux groupes
politiques que par le sujet traité
l'opération barkan je voudrais également
vous remercier monsieur le ministre de
l'europe des affaires étrangères madame
la ministre des armées d'avoir bien
voulu y participer
loin de tout esprit politique
ce débat nous permettra notamment de
vous faire part des travaux qu amener la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense
depuis plus d'un an au moment où
l'opinion publique semble s'interroger
il est sans doute bon que les
institutions jouent leur rôle en
permettant une expression diverses mais
constructives ce débat c'est d'abord
l'occasion de saluer une fois encore
l'engagement exceptionnel de nos
militaires
rappelons-nous le prix très lourd qu'ils
ont payé avec 55 morts est aujourd'hui
un souvenir plus particulier pour le
fils de jean-marie bockel notre ancien
collègue qui fêterait aujourd'hui même
ses 30 ans nous nous inclinons devant
leur mémoire
notre reconnaissance et notre soutien
sont bien sûr aussi aux nombreux blessés
nous ne les oublions pas expliqué leur
action expliquer le sens de leur mission
comme nous allons le faire cet après
midi c'est sans doute la meilleure
manière de leur rendre hommage
le 22 avril 2013
nous avons autorisé la prolongation de
l'opération serval conformément à
l'article 35 de la constitution
près de huit ans plus tard serval est
devenu barkan et la france est toujours
engagé au sahel
en huit ans les modalités de notre
engagement au beaucoup évolué le nombre
de nos soldats a fortement augmenté
3000 à l'origine puis 4500 enfin 5100
l'ennemi est là c'est aussi beaucoup
transformé l'état islamique au grand
sahara est montée en puissance et les
attaques jihadi se sont étendus dans le
centre du mali dans la zone des trois
frontières puis au burkina faso et
menace maintenant tout le golfe de
guinée
quelques jours avant le sommet de
n'djamena
il est donc temps de faire ensemble le
point sur cet engagement de longue
haleine et de tracer de nouvelles
perspectives à s'attaquer à cet égard
savoir si 600 soldats vont ou non
quitter barkan c'est certes important
mais n'apportent pas totalement la
réponse que nous attendons nous
souhaitons avant tout comprendre la
stratégie du gouvernement pour la
période à venir
en effet un double constat s'impose à
nous d'une part sur le plan militaire
barkan a remporté c'est indéniable de
très nombreux succès tactiques nos
forces armées il faut le rom faut le
rappeler ont remporté des succès
considérables notamment avec l'opération
bourrasques ces derniers temps de
nombreux chefs djihadistes ont pu être
neutralisé ce qui a en partie
désorganiser les groupes terroristes
en outre nous sommes parvenus à
mobiliser le soutien d'un certain nombre
d'alliés européens
même si les moyens qu'ils ont mis en
oeuvre nous paraissent encore
insuffisant la force takouba a pu
commencer entrer en action les armées de
nos alliés du g5 sahel ont également
progressé
souvent en payant le prix du sang nous
devons leur rendre hommage car le tribut
qu'ils ont payé est indiscutablement un
prix très fort dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
ainsi grâce à la pression exercée en
permanence par nos forces et par celle
de nos alliés la constitution d'un
sanctuaire jihadiste a pu être évité ce
qui était l'objectif initial
un autre constat cependant s'impose à
nous le dénouement de cette crise qui
dure depuis huit ans ne sera
certainement pas militaire nous le
savons la solution ne peut être que
politique et par conséquent elle est
essentiellement du ressort des maliens
eux mêmes or les accords d'alger n'ont
pas été appliqués pire le nouveau coup
d'état au mali nous donne parfois
l'impression d'un retour en arrière de
près de huit ans dans ces conditions
allons-nous signer pour un nouveau bail
de 8 ans et que se passera-t-il si au
terme de cette période
rien n'avait changé sur le plan
politique au mali certes nous ne pensons
pas bien évidemment qu'un retrait brutal
de nos armées soit la bonne réponse
ce ne serait ni conforme à nos intérêts
ni à celui de nos alliés qui on demande
qui ont demandé notre aide nos choix nos
choix doivent au contraire consolider
les acquis de barkan et non les
sacrifiés mais nous sommes en droit
compte tenu de notre engagement et du
prix que nous payons d'attendre des
progrès sur la voie de la réconciliation
nationale malienne
lors du sommet ne jamais n'a qu'elle
sera monsieur me lisent affaires
étrangères madame la ministre des armées
quel sera le message de la france à nos
alliés sahélien en somme c'est votre
feuille de route pour la période à venir
que nous souhaitons connaître les
français veulent tout simplement savoir
quel est le plan du gouvernement pour 15
jours
la france puisse retirer ses forces sans
craindre un nouveau séisme
de notre côté notre avons mis en
évidence le caractère crucial du
développement économique et par
conséquent celui de l'aide publique au
développement
c'est essentiel pour lutter contre les
causes profondes du terrorisme au sahel
sinon nous ne traiterons que les
symptômes et les populations locales
finiront par nous voir comme des troupes
d'occupation
nous avons dépensé 900 millions d'euros
pour barkan en 2019 contre seulement 85
millions d'euros en aides publiques au
développement net pour le mali certes
nous ne sommes pas seuls l'alliance à
elle créé en 2017 a mobilisé des sommes
aussi très important toutefois il nous
reste très difficile d'atteindre des
régions qui en ont le plus besoin
particulièrement au nord du mali c'est
pourtant la seule façon d'offrir des
perspectives aux jeunes de ces
territoires
éducation santé services publics de base
c'est là les admis les améliorations
concrètes que les populations attendent
et qu'elles doivent voir enfin arriver
la future loi d'orientation sur la
solidarité internationale que nous
allons enfin pouvoir examiner dans
quelques semaines sera l'occasion de
réorienter plus encore ses priorités
enfin notre débat d'aujourd'hui doit
être l'occasion d'aborder des
préoccupations plus immédiates en
particulier la protection de nos soldats
constitue pour nous une priorité absolue
qu'en est il du renforcement du blindage
des véhicules légers que nous attendons
encore ne faut-il pas au basculer dans
la mesure du possible vers davantage
d'aero mobilité puisque les principaux
attentats qui touche nos troupes ont
lieu dans les transports automobiles
dans les convois le automobile à cet
égard
j'ose croire que l'actualisation de la
loi de programmation militaire
nous permettra aussi d'aborder
directement ce sujet vous l'aurez
compris monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre nous sommes loin de toute
posture la diversité des points de vue
qui vont s'exprimer
le montrera nous sommes face à une
situation difficile à une situation
complexe
il n'y a pas de solution toute faite
mais nous devons nous confronter
ensemble à cette complexité
c'est là le rôle et l'utilité du
parcours du parlement mes chers
collègues
ce débat est aussi un symbole il
s'adresse à nos concitoyens pour qu'ils
sachent que partout où la france se bat
c'est pour faire progresser la paix
quant à nos soldats qui patrouillent en
ce moment même dans les déserts brûlants
et dangereux du sahel puisse-t-il
accueillir ce débat comme la marque de
notre confiance et de notre soutien
ils sont la fierté de la france merci
monsieur le président
dans la suite de notre débat la parole
les deux orateurs des groupes et le
premier orateur inscrits monsieur
ludovic et pour le groupe lieu
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant il a cinq
minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
des armées
monsieur le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères monsieur le
président quand bon mes chers collègues
permettez-moi d'entamer mon propos en
rendant effectivement un hommage appuyé
à nos soldats à ces femmes et ces hommes
d'exception engagé au sahel à la
combativité et au dévouement inégalable
leur négation est un modèle pour nous
tous je veux leur dire au nom du groupe
r des pays combien nous sommes fiers
d'eux combien nous leur sommes
reconnaissants et qu'ils peuvent compter
sur notre soutien indéfectible à tous
nos soldats tombés au service de notre
nation j'aurais également un hommage ému
et sincère la tenue de ce débat tombe à
point nommé puisque à quelques jours
d'un sommet déterminant n'djamena il
nous donne l'occasion de réaffirmer la
scion capital que mène la force barkan
et de renouveler toute notre confiance à
notre président de la république et à
son gouvernement
ces groupes armés terroristes que nos
soldats combattent hier avec l'opération
serval pour les empêcher de provoquer la
chute d'un état allié
le mali est aujourd'hui avec barkan pour
les empêcher de faire de la bande
sahélo-saharienne une base arrière du
terrorisme de la taille de l'europe
cela représente bien une menace elle est
bien tangible mais en passant de servat
à la barre cannes nous sommes passés
d'une guerre d'intervention rapide et
courtes à une guerre d'un tout autre
genre
nous avons pleinement conscience que
sans nos soldats sur place aux côtés des
armées ssa eliane cette menace s'étendra
demain sur toute l'afrique de l'ouest
et c'est parce que nos partenaires
européens partagent pleinement de cette
évaluation qu'il s'investit chaque jour
un peu plus au sahel
cela me donne l'occasion de saluer
l'engagement de nos alliés européens
que ce soit au sein de la task force
takouba ou dans d'autres opérations
depuis le sommet de pau barkan a
fortement augmenté le rythme de
neutralisation des groupes terroristes
et la montée en puissance des forces
aériennes est encourageante malgré le
fait qu'elle ne soit toujours pas en
mesure de prendre la relève total de
barkan et d'affronter seul les menaces
des groupes armés au côté du rôle
essentiel de la france
une addition de faiblesse ne fait pas
une force si nous a remis remporter
chaque jour des victoires tactiques
il nous faut intégrer que la crise est
aussi politique et économique comme
stipulé dans les quatre piliers
complémentaires du sommet de pau nous
devons transformer ensemble les gains
acquis durement sur le terrain en
progrès politiques économiques et
sociaux et trouver un moyen de sortir la
proche 3d diplomatie défense
développement de sa phase incantatoire
mais pour cela nous avons besoin
d'engagements forts de la part de nos
partenaires sahéliens et surtout malien
avec une feuille de route claire en
faveur d'une bonne gouvernance politique
démocratique et du développement des
services publics dans les zones fragiles
je pense notamment aux zones du nord
elles sont nécessaires pour restaurer la
confiance de l'état de la tenue
d'élections en mars 2022 de la
préservation de l'espace humanitaire et
du développement des nouveaux pans
économiques de la lutte contre la
corruption les trafics humains de
stupéfiants et de produits de
contrebande en tous genres qui
gangrènent la société et favorise la
sécurité et l'instabilité
après la guinée-bissau le mali est en
train de devenir progressivement un
narco état dans lequel les trafiquants
achète aient conscience et les votes de
la lutte aussi contre la désinformation
avec l'arrivée de fake news qui viennent
progressivement salir l'image de nos
forces et de notre pays
du racisme à rebours à
l'anticolonialisme primaire en passant
par la réécriture de l'histoire
leur caractéristique commune et
simplement le dénigrement de l'action
passée présente et future de notre pays
en afrique
nous le voyons bien en parallèle du
cadre strictement militaire il y à toute
une série d'autres combats à mener qui
prennent de temps qu'ils prennent
beaucoup de temps et qu'il s'agit de
concrétiser rapidement sous peine
d'enlisement
six ans après l'accord de paix d'alger
en 2015 visant à rétablir la paix et la
réconciliation au mali comment se
fait-il que sa mise en oeuvre soit
toujours à ses balbutiements
monsieur le ministre par quels moyens
politiques et diplomatiques
envisagez-vous d'intervenir quant à la
mise en oeuvre concrète de cet accord de
paix avec l acteur avancé et dialoguer
alors que le paysage régional comprend
une myriade d'acteurs locaux armés ayant
leurs propres agendas locaux
comment lutter contre
l'instrumentalisation malveillante des
opinions publiques locales et la
propagation de fausses informations à
des fins politiques intérieures ou par
des puissances étrangères qui sape nos
efforts communs le temps joue contre
nous et c'est malheureusement une règle
universelle plus d'une opération
militaire dure plus la population locale
a tendance à attribuer aux soldats la
faute de certaines situations pacifier
son pays en faisant naître un réel
sentiment d'appartenance nationale
passera par le développement
tous ces objectifs ne pourront être
atteints sans l'aide de la france et des
acteurs étatiques et économiques sur
place je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue vous donnez pas
la parole à notre collègue jean noël
guérini pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
chaque la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre monsieur
ministre michard collègues
merci cher président comme bon d'avoir
initié ce débat à un an de l'élection
présidentielle française évidemment à
quelques jours du sommet g5 sahel à
n'djamena ne comptez pas sur moi pour
polémiquer sur un dossier qui engage la
france
la présence de 5000 sang de nos enfants
de la nation basé sur ce territoire
celle où ça rien appel à des échanges
responsable loin des querelles
politiciennes
j'entends ici et là des velléités et me
en retrait de nos forces armées
après le décès de ces cartes est un de
nos soldats en raison de son coude et de
l'intérêt de cette mission que d'aucuns
trouvent discutable je ne vais pas
distribuer des bons ou les mauvais
points d'un choix stratégique et
géopolitique
en revanche je tiens à poser des enjeux
actuels de cette opération qui
s'éternise malheureusement mais est-ce
cette durée qui peut justifier un
retrait voire une ré
actions de notre niveau d'un grand
chemin alors même qu antonio guterres
s16 dans son rapport trimestriel
relatives à la situation au mahdi sur le
degré de violence auxquels est
confrontée la population
rappelons quand même des raisons de
notre présence au mali
à la demande du gouvernement de ce pays
barkan c'est un gage de stabilité pour
une zone souffrance un besoin réel pour
contenir le terrorisme et ses nombreuses
répercussions en europe et sur notre
territoire un engagement la formation de
militaires maliens un projet a régné
dead à la population une influence de la
france à l'occasion des voeux aux armées
manuel macron a rappelé que je le cite
face aux risques de destruction des
relations internationales et de notre
société
les armées françaises ont été un facteur
de stabilité de force et de résistance
et barkan est entièrement résumé par
cette phrase notre présence a pour
objectif d'assurer une sécurité pérenne
de ce territoire en partenariat avec les
forces de bamako et du g5 sahel la zone
des trois frontières à cheval entre le
mali le niger et le burkina faso est
l'un des poumons des tombes djihadistes
sous la bannière de l' état islamique
dans le grand sahara branche locale de
lui
l'enjeu est bel et bien de contenir le
terrorisme dont nous mesurons hélas les
répercussions provoqué en france et en
europe
ben c'est effectivement une présence
militaire mais ce sont aussi des projets
des dalles appup à la population en
facilitant l'accès à l'eau à l'énergie à
la santé aux médicaments gratuits ils
sont destinés à accompagner la
population plutôt que de la laisser
traverser la méditerranée dans des
conditions inhumaines
ils sont sans doute insuffisante j'en
conviens mais ils sont néanmoins
indispensable
l'avenir de ces populations n'est pas
dans la migration mais bien dans le
développement du mali et de la bande
sahélo saharienne
c'est pourquoi marc n est également un
engagement à la formation de militaires
maliens base de lutte active contre le
terrorisme qui ronge ce territoire en
terrorisant la population pérenniser
notre intervention si durable soit elle
aussi douloureuse soit elle
si cher soit elle demeure un enjeu
géostratégique un jeu de coopération un
enjeu humain car notre engagement est
l'une des bases de notre influence en
afrique et dans le monde
oui notre présence est une dépense jédir
importante milliards d'euros par an mais
nous ne sommes plus seuls 55 du
transport de personnel et près de 45 du
transport matériels ont été réalisés par
les pays alliés européens
notre politique d'influencé matière de
défense verit mieux que les projections
budgétaires contrainte et la crème du
nombre de pertes humaines parmi les
militaires et que répondre mes chers
collègues à cette émotion sinon de se
remémorer ici à ces tribunes
l'intervention de jean marie bockel
notre ami alors sénateur après la perte
de son fils je le cite nous sommes
infiniment triste et fière aussi de
notre enfant c'était un soldat engagé
qui savaient pourquoi ils étaient là
cher collègue madame le ministre
monsieur ministre soyons fiers du
travail accompli par nos troupes et ne
les perturbe pas dans leur mission par
nos discussions qui peuvent sembler sur
terre et à thouars voirie respectueuses
de leur engagement au service de la
liberté au service de la sécurité est au
service de la france merci merci vaut
cher
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue
le président pierre laurent pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président madame et
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je veux d'abord salué la tenue de ce
débat et remercié le président d'autres
de notre commission d'en avoir pris
l'initiative il n'est plus acceptable de
placer le parlement devant le fait
accompli alors que dans quelques jours à
djamena le président de la république
s'apprête à annoncer une fois de plus
d'importantes décisions
madame la ministre vous avez déclaré
devant notre commission que dire que la
france est englué dans une guerre sans
fin est faux nous nous pensons que rien
ne serait plus faux que de ne pas
interroger sans concession les résultats
de l'opération barkan
vous ne trouverez pas plus farouches
opposants terroristes islamistes que les
communistes les démocrates que nous
soutenons un travers le monde sont
partout pourchassés et tués par ces
groupes et nos combats émancipateurs
sont menacés par leur vision
obscurantiste
mais huit ans de guerre au mali ont-ils
éteint ou propager le feu du terrorisme
islamiste et de tous les entrepreneurs
de violence le mali vit-il plus en paix
qu'il y a huit ans poser ces questions
c'est malheureusement y répondre et de
plus en plus nombreux les maliens les
populations civiles des pays du sahel
mais aussi des militaires des diplomates
et des universitaires français pose ces
questions avec nous pour un coût de la
guerre exorbitant près d'un milliard
d'euros par an depuis huit ans et plus
de 5000 soldats engagés nous infligeons
c'est vrai des pertes à des groupes
djihadistes mais nous ne faisons pas
reculer la violence et les pertes
humaines
elles ne font que s'amplifier cinquante
cinq militaires français ont perdu la
vie 5000 malien soldats des armées
locales ou populations civils ont été
tués depuis 2015 plus de 4000 sur
l'ensemble de la région rien qu'en 2020
un demi million de déplacés dans la sous
région
la situation humanitaire politique et
économie
du mali en pire et dans cette
déstabilisation sociale et politique
les islamistes continuent de déployer
leur sinistre entreprise les leçons des
guerres menées au nom de la guerre au
terrorisme ne sont pas tirés elle laisse
à chaque fois les pays en proie au chaos
pour des décennies la désintégration la
libye en est un exemple
elle est d'ailleurs directement à
l'origine d'une partie des violences
armées dans le nord du mali
dans quel état laisserons-nous le mali
et les autres pays de la région si nous
poursuivons dans cette direction censé
venir pour protéger le mali nous jouons
apprentis sorciers réveillant les
divisions pour trouver des alliés
prétendant choisir entre les bons et les
mauvais groupes armés nourrissant la
relance des conflits communautaires
jouent un jeu trouble avec le mouvement
national de libération de l'azawad
suscitant la défiance des maliens devant
le risque d'une partition du mali quand
erin ray la mainmise de groupes armés
islamistes ou non sur le nord c'est
d'ailleurs pour ces raisons que les
accords d'alger ne peuvent être invoqués
comme la solution politique et doivent
être profondément révisé les islamistes
prospère sur ses divisions recrute en
exploitant le désespoir de populations
spoliées de toutes parts nous devons
tirer les leçons et tourner la page de
barkan car l'impasse est certaine et
créer les conditions d'un départ
programmé de nos troupes pour le su lui
substituer un nouvel agenda politique
économique et de sécurité pour le mali
et la région cela ne se fera pas en un
jour
car le mal est fait et il ne s'agit pas
d'abandonner le mali au chaos
l'agenda de retrait doit être discutée
avec le mali l'union africaine et l'onu
est adossé à une nouvelle réponse de
sécurité multilatérale et africaines et
un nouvel agenda de coopération
notre appui militaire doit être
recentrée sur l'appui aux armées locales
en préparant la formule d'un comité
d'état major conjoint des forces
africaines excluant les puissances
étrangères la france doit appuyer avec
vigueur
la feuille de route de louzac a baptisé
faire taire les armes participer à
toutes initiatives multilatérales visant
le désarmement de tous les groupes armés
non étatiques ainsi et c'est très
important que la lutte contre les flux
financiers illicites qui finance les
trafics les violences et les guerres en
afrique
mais plus que tout c'est notre agenda
politique qui doit changer la france et
l'union européenne doivent appuyer par
tous les moyens et en priorité sur les
territoires les plus délaissés par les
pouvoirs publics
de vastes au plan d'action pour le
développement
les populations africaines et
singulièrement sa jeunesse ont les
ressources de le construire et de les
entretenir
les pays africains doivent sortir de la
domination et d'un modèle d'économie
extraverti tourner vers les besoins des
multinationales et d'élite aisée
corrompu car seul mâle profonde nous
sommes encore les complices la france
doit massivement accroître son aide
publique au développement en révisant
ses objectifs et agir sans tarder pour
libérer en faveur de ces pays des droits
de tirage spéciaux non utilisés par les
pays riches en vue durant déploiement
des services publics de l'éducation dans
la police de la justice des droits des
femmes d'une fiscalité générant des
ressources endogènes d'une maîtrise
locale des ressources et de la
valorisation des capacités productives
propres tel est l'intérêt des africains
et elle est aussi notre intérêt le
développement ne doit pas rester le
troisième des alibis une stratégie
militaire et diplomatique dans l'impasse
mais il doit être lambas l'ambition
autour de laquelle tout doit s'organiser
c'est monsieur le président
donner la parole à monsieur olivier
cigolotti pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
vous avez un parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission mais chers
collègues comme témoin tout d'abord mes
chers collègues de remercier à mon tour
et au nom de notre groupe
notre président christian cambon qui a
sollicité et obtenu ce débat très
attendu sur tous les bancs c'est
hémicycle en effet depuis neuf ans que
nous avons débuté notre intervention au
mas liés au sahel
ce n'est que la seconde fois que nous
avons l'opportunité d'avoir un débat de
fond sur la stratégie les enjeux et les
perspectives de l'opération barkan
en premier lieu je tiens je salue
unanimement l'engagement opérationnel de
nos forces mobilisées sur les différents
théâtres d'opération de cette bande
sahélo saharienne
au mali comme au niger sur ce territoire
grand comme l'europe toute entière et au
climat des plus arides
nos militaires mènent une lutte sans
relâche contre le terrorisme et le
fanatisme et parfois au péril de leur
vie
je veux avoir une pensée pour nos
soldats tombés au combat
leur ferme armes leurs proches leurs
familles mes pensées vont également à
cet instant un autre collègue et ami
jean marie bockel les opérations serval
puis barkan ont permis d'éviter
l'installation d'un califat territoriale
au mali et la création d'un sanctuaire
djihadistes comparable à celui instauré
au levant par des ch
cependant malgré de nombreuses victoires
stratégique et la neutralisation de
nombreux chefs de groupes armés
terroristes
force est de constater que la guerre est
loin d'être gagné l'histoire nous
démontre que l'intervention de pays
occidentaux sur les théâtres
d'opérations extérieures s'apparente le
plus souvent à des conflits asymétriques
force militaire conventionnelle d'un
côté groupes armés terroristes noyé au
sein des populations de l'autre pourtant
cette asymétrie ne confère pas une
supériorité très évidente et ne permet
pas à nos force de vaincre la
détermination l'imagination et la
mobilité opérationnelle de ces groupes
armés qui évolue en effectif réduit et
sur un terrain qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement
force est de constater que la situation
sécuritaire en afrique de l'ouest
loin de s'être améliorée s'est
véritablement dégradé le conflit
originel au nord du mali s'est
régionalisé s'étendant désormais vers le
sud jusqu'au burkina faso et produisant
une contagion jusqu'aux pays riverains
du golfe de guinée au conflit
interethnique plus locaux se mêle
désormais les revendications
idéologiques et religieuses ainsi les
forces françaises apparaissent bien seul
sur ce terrain depuis neuf ans
l'engouement des autres pays européens à
s'engager aux côtés de la france demeure
peu visible par l'opinion publique est
seulement madame la ministre parce que
la france est encore l'une des seules
nations européennes à disposer d'une
armée d'emplois pourtant la poursuite de
notre engagement dans cette bande
sahélo-saharienne nécessite de façon
incontournable une coopération
européenne et internationale élargie et
renforcée ainsi qu'une prise de
conscience de l'intérêt de tous les
états membres de l'union de lutter
collectivement contre le terrorisme au
plus près de ses racines dans cette
région du monde
une coopération européenne qui ne peut
se limiter à la mission européenne de
formation de l'armée malienne qui
s'inscrit certes dans une approche
globale pour renforcer les capacités
militaires en vue de garantir
l'intégrité territoriale une coopération
européenne qui doit aller désormais au
delà d'une coopération limitée au g5
sahel sens et permettent aux armées
locales d'intervenir de façon autonome
sur la zone des trois frontières
ce dispositif nous paraît à ce jour
insuffisant pour faire face à la
progression vers le sud de la zone d
influence des groupes armés terroristes
et doit rapidement s'étendre de façon
effective à tous les états membres de la
cedeao que sont le sénégal la côte
d'ivoire le ghana le togo ou le bénin il
s'avère désormais indispensable
d'associer plus largement les pays
riverains du golfe de guinée lors du
sommet de pau les chefs d'états du g5
sel ont réaffirmé leur volonté de
renforcer cette force conjointe mais son
élargissement sera-t-il évoqué lors du
prochain sommet d'un général lorsque
l'on évoque la collaboration européenne
il faut également évoquer la force
takouba task force que vous appelez de
vos jeux et madame la ministre pour
soutenir l'opération barkan sept
composants
de forces spéciales étaient également
censée matérialiser l'engagement de
l'europe et renforcer la logique du
partenariat de combat au delà des bonnes
intentions de nos voisins les premiers
éléments des forces spéciales françaises
et estoniennes sont arrivés sur le
théâtre d'opérations mais qu'en est il
de l'engagement de nos autres
partenaires
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous
indiquer de façon précise comment
s'effectuera la montée en puissance de
takouba une stratégie qui repose sur les
deux piliers que sont européanisation et
sa réalisation sera t elle suffisante
pour sortir du conflit
la question reste posée et sans les
citer nous ne pouvons ignorer les
velléités de certains états puissance
très intéressé par cette région du monde
et plus particulièrement par le
continent africain
alors certes il n'y a pas de petites
victoires dans une guerre à condition
qu'il soit envisageable de la gagner
celle que la france mène au sahel avec
l'opération marque anne et ses alliés ne
pourra se solder par une implication
politique plus forte
à commencer par celles des pays
concernés nous sommes tous conscients
que l'absence de l'état dans ses
missions régaliennes d'administration
publique de services de santé
d'éducation ou d'accès à des besoins
vitaux ne peut que favoriser l'emprise
des groupes armés terroristes sur les
populations locales
difficile dans ces conditions de
percevoir l'état comme protecteur et non
pas comme prédateur sans un état plus
fort la paix sera impossible une
véritable issue politique passe
inexorablement par des politiques des de
développement plus forte est au service
des populations sahéliennes avec une
stratégie claire des pays des
bénéficiaires et des acteurs de l'aide
mais également avec des fonds
conséquents qui ne peuvent encore être
le fruit d'une collaboration
internationale
pourtant aujourd'hui il s'avère souvent
plus facile de trouver des financements
pour faire la guerre que pour rétablir
la paix alors certes l'ensemble de ces
éléments doit nous amener à une
évolution de notre engagement dans ce
conflit même s'il n'est pas envisageable
d'opérer une réduction massive de
l'empreinte françaises sur le terrain
une réflexion en termes d'accompagnement
à forte valeur ajoutée de type drones
renseignement ou frappe
ciblée de noms pas être occultée à
l'heure actuelle le besoin prioritaire
et d'établir une stratégie claire et un
calendrier de transition adapté aux
forces en présence car la situation en
afrique de l'ouest demeure d'une grande
complexité
pour conclure mon propos permettez moi
de vous livrer deux axes qui à notre
sens pour être sources d'évolutions
positives
à quelques jours du sommet de la gamme
ena ce dernier devra bien entendu
permettre de voir réaffirmé la volonté
du pays déjà des pays du g5 sahel mais
également de solliciter une véritable
implication des pays qui sont désormais
menacés enfin le nouveau locataire de la
maison blanche a déclaré il ya quelques
jours vouloir renouer avec le
multilatéralisme et réinstaurer le
dialogue avec l'union africaine afin je
cite de faire face aux périls les plus
imminents
mes chers collègues l'issue de ce
conflit sera politique ou ne sera pas
réfléchissons à ce que disait paul
valéry
les guerres sont des gens qui ne se
connaissent pas et qui s'entretuent
parce que d'autres qui se connaissent ne
parviennent pas à se mettre d'accord
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue jean-marc des skinny pour le
gros socialistes écologistes et
républicains
vous fait dire à jean marc todeschini ma
joie de le voir à ces deux tribunes
voilà merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je ne peux commencer mon
intervention en ayant une pensée à mon
tour et au nom du groupe socialiste pour
nos militaires leurs familles et leurs
proches
à ce jour plus de 5000 militaires sont
engagés dans l'opération barkan depuis
2000 13 55 militaires et ont perdu la
vie dont cela a été rappelé par un
collègue
le fils de notre collègue jean-marie des
femmes et des hommes
sierre et libre qui ont fait de leur vie
un engagement au service de notre
drapeau
mais plus encore une certaine idée de la
liberté alors secrétaire d'état à vos
côtés monsieur le ministre je garde le
souvenir de celles et ceux que j'ai
croisés de leur professionnalisme
indiscutable de leur très haut niveau
d'entraînement de le détail de leur
détermination sans faille de leur
courage en somme ce qui m'a frappé et
qui restera gravé en moi c'est que
revient toujours dans les yeux et les
mots des proches de celles et ceux mort
au combat le sens du devoir
il y à cette phrase nous n'aurions
jamais pu le ou la dissuader de partir
en opération d'être côtés de ses
camarades pour servir dans un monde où
l'on ne cesse d'observer des effets de
l'individualisme
nos militaires dans la plupart sont très
jeunes démentent les idées reçues
ensemble avec leur famille et leurs
proches avec tous les français aussi
ils ne font qu'un il est important de
rappeler cet engagement régulièrement et
de le mettre en valeur
je ne reviendrai pas longuement sur les
raisons qui ont conduit à la situation
actuelle
ces éléments sont connus loin des fêtes
d'effry use et les réseaux sociaux
l'opération barkan a été lancé le 1er ou
faisant suite à l'opération serval ils
ont en oeuvre à partir du 11 janvier
rappelons nous toujours pour quelques
heures à l'appel du président
démocratiquement élu du mali françois
hollande président de la république
française
alors commandant en chef de nos armées a
dû prendre la difficile décision de
recourir à l'usagé de la force pour
protéger la liberté à plus de civils
kilomètres de chez nous voilà la seule
raison de notre présence au mali la
liberté seront toutes et tous d'accord
ici et par delà les bancs pour saluer le
courage de cette décision
celle du président françois hollande la
france est honoré de ne pas rester les
bras croisés dans le peuple malien a
fait appel à elle cette décision était
nécessaire elle était responsable
elle était digne dans les faits cette
première bataille a été remportée en
quelques semaines
dès les premières heures le dispositif
français se déployer démontrant une fois
supplémentaire les capacités
opérationnelles exceptionnelle de
projection de l'ensemble de nos forces
armées
oui la france réparti d'un club mondial
très fermé celui des nations capables de
projeter massivement leurs forces dans
le cadre d'opérations extérieures au nom
de nos valeurs ses capacités militaires
exceptionnels conféreront dossier le
concert des nations qui ont une
responsabilité supplémentaire dans notre
pays a pleinement conscience
ces derniers temps nous entendons les
nous lisons des choses insupportables
pour la raison dénuée de tout fondement
rationnel il est essentiel de rappeler
régulièrement les faits les causes et
les objectifs ne pas laisser s'installer
des rumeurs nauséabondes pour notre pays
mais plus encore et plus largement pour
la démocratie
la france n'est pas un pays impérialiste
colonisateurs ou des stabilisateurs la
france ne poursuit qu'un seul but la
paix d'abord et avant tout autre
considération la paix dans la dignité
pour les peuples la paix ici au mali et
dans les pays voisins pour que les
peuples de cette région puisse avoir la
possibilité de vivre librement sans se
trouver sur le joug quotidien du
terrorisme et de son aboutissement
politique dans la communauté
internationale c'est ce que cela
représente pour les peuples afghans
irakiens si rien et tous les autres
produire la véracité des faits n'a rien
d'artificiel
dans un contexte de
développement de suspicion notamment
notamment dans le pot pourri qui est de
plus en plus souvent un quai de plus en
plus souvent internet où tout se mélange
face à face aux attaques dans l'espace
cyber dont nous savons qu'au moins deux
grandes puissances des hits plus en
faire une pratique assidue l'a rappelé
la parole des faits est essentiel car il
faut toujours revenir aux causes
profondes pour déterminer la situation
telle qu'elle se présente en ce sens ne
serait-il pas plus urgent d'associer
régulièrement les parlementaires et de
leur donner notamment plus de moyens
afin que les airs qu'ils exercent leur
pouvoir de contrôle sur l'exécutif
un pouvoir tradition traditionnellement
relégué au second plan sur ces questions
sensibles
nous avons ici c'est l'occasion de
changer le prisme et d'améliorer nos
pratiques pour ne plus laisser se
diffuser le poison des rumeurs et
revenir à l'objectivité des faits si
tactiquement le succès de nos opérations
militaires est indiscutable il est tout
aussi essentiel de débattre de notre
trajet stratégie comme nous le faisons
aujourd'hui en décembre 2015
le gouvernement par la voix de son
ministre de la défense d'alors vous n'en
tenez c'est le ministre aujourd'hui mise
affaires étrangères vous posez une
question qui avec le recul apparaît
encore plus fondamentale qui est
l'ennemi pour agir sereinement et
efficacement la nature de la réponse
doit nous conduire à reposer
régulièrement cette question cet ennemi
émouvant en évolution permanente émergé
dans les sociétés pour déstabiliser des
états aient tenté de diffuser un
ensemble idéologique car vent de la
liberté avec toujours ne l'oublions
jamais la perspective d'instauration de
proto état de type dèche
cette situation ne relève ni les
angoisses l'idée fantasmée du monde
occidental
c'est la réalité du terrain celle
décrite notamment dans le livre blanc de
2013 pour faire face la france n'a
jamais eu la culture et l'obsession de
la guerre préventive
là où d'autres pays ont pu s'y confondre
pendant le risque de s'y perdre
moralement culturellement économiquement
les comparaisons avec ces pays si elle
pourrait avoir le mérite de questionner
notre stratégie ce qui est nécessaire
c'est comparaison retomberez
immédiatement les profs déchets car la
france fidèle à ses valeurs et à sa
tradition à intégrer la sécurité absolue
a intégré que la sécurité absolue est un
leurre et que l'ennemi doit sans cesse
être redéfinies au plus juste et en
réaction au mali comme ailleurs notre
stratégie ne varie pas la france ne mène
aucune guerre préventive
la stratégie française et défensives et
dissuasive je le disais le débat
d'aujourd'hui est nécessaire parce qu'il
s'agit de toujours questionné et
redéfinir l'ennemi au plus juste parce
qu'il s'agit aussi de dépasser le simple
cadre militaire pour ne pas sombrer dans
le chaos ou des forces obscures connu
souhaite entraîner le td pays la région
et en premier lieu le mali les
opérations militaires même couronné de
succès ne suffisent pas elles peuvent
même conduire à l'impasse sans une
approche globale politique diplomatique
économique éducative et judiciaire
nous savons une stratégie durable repose
sur cet éventail de dispositions madame
la ministre
le sentiment grandissant à la fois dans
les médias mais aussi à bien des égards
sur le terrain opérationnel et parfois
même jusque dans nos armées
c'est que ces dispositions par delà les
opérations militaires apparaissent de
moins en moins visibles madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre vous le
savez de négociations font poser
je me permets d'en aligner quelques unes
où en sommes-nous sur le terrain
diplomatique notamment au sein du g100
sahel nous le savons la situation en
libye est loin d'être stabilisée
quels sont les effets de la crise
libyenne pour la zone de travail de
barkan
peut-on s'attendre à une nouvelle
attitude des états unis et la nouvelle
administration du président weiten sans
tomber dans reste opérationnel
représenté par la publication d'un
calendrier at-elle échéance les pays
auront ils localement suffisamment de
moyens pour prendre le relais militaire
en d'autres termes ou en somme nulle où
en sommes nous de la formation et de
l'accompagnement dans les champs
économiques éducatives
comment accompagnons nous les pays
menacés quels sont les projets
structurants qui permettront aux
territoires du nord où la misère est
grandissante de la main ce socle dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire
pourriez-vous par ailleurs nous indiquer
les mesures prises sur cet aspect
particulièrement en somme
madame le ministre monsieur le ministre
nous vous posons la question directement
et sans détour quel est précisément la
stratégie de france au mali au sein de
l'opération voire cannes et plus
largement
merci ma parole est un autre collègue
joël guerriau pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
pour cinq minutes je président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président avec
mission affaires étrangères et de la
défense
le groupe les indépendantes chez un
rendre hommage à nos soldats à celles et
à ceux qui ont perdu la vue et vie qui
ont été blessés et à tous les militaires
qui sont actuellement encore engagé à
leur famille la mission confiée à notre
armée mais est celle de lutter contre
les groupes armés terroristes
elle a admirablement accompli et
continue de le faire
nos soldats ont ainsi libéré les villes
occupées et poursuivre les terroristes
partout où ils se trouvent
ce n'est pas au moment où le bilan de
l'opération barkan s'améliore qu'il faut
baisser la garde alors que de nouveaux
entrants européens viennent nous épauler
le principal effet de l'opération barkan
et de prévenir l'effondrement des états
et la création d'un sanctuaire par les
terroristes
tout retrait donnerait satisfaction aux
activistes qui sont par nature nos
ennemis ne nous y trompons pas les
armées locales sont encore loin d'être
en mesure de lutter seul contre ces
groupes
un retrait de nos forces seraient
suivies d'une nette dégradation des
conditions de sécurité qui entraînerait
des déplacements massifs de populations
au coeur du sahel
contrairement à la désinformation des
réseaux sociaux la population malienne
dans une très forte majorité aspirent au
maintien de la présence militaire
française
notre pays peut s'enorgueillir de son
action le sacrifice de nos soldats pour
une juste cause n'est pas vain la tâche
est considérable pour fonder une paix
durable
les nations de la zone doivent renforcer
leur unité les états et leurs services
publics doivent également être capable
d'assurer une présence auprès de toutes
les populations et surtout les
territoires j'illustrerai mes propos par
un exemple en évoquant une ville que je
connais bien
en 1995 j'ai initié une coopération
décentralisée entre ma ville et la ville
de 4e cat iq est une garnison
limitrophes à bamako aujourd'hui la
situation est catastrophique
cette commune de plus de 100000
habitants recevaient une aide de l'
agence nationale pour le développement
de 30 millions de francs cfa et bien
maintenant elle ne reçoit plus que 9
millions
est ce que vous connaissez beaucoup de
villes pauvres qui pourrait supporter
une baisse de 70 % de son budget les
agents territoriaux ne sont plus
rémunérés à bamako il est de plus en
plus difficile de ceux de circuler la
misère se développe par manque de
travail et de ressources alimentaires
mais aussi par l'arrivée de déplacés
fuyant les zones dangereuses
nos amis malien souffre sur le plan
économique touristique sécuritaire
politique sur le plan économique les
partenaires d'hier commençaient à
manquer d'eau fortement les aidants sont
de plus en plus rare sur le plan
touristique les villes de ségou de mopti
connaissent un flux qui connaissent un
afflux régulier de touristes ont perdu
une ressource précieuse et sur le plan
sécuritaire bien sûr dans les zones les
plus exposées autour et au terrorisme
des milliers d'écoles sont fermées
depuis cinq ans il en est ainsi vous le
savez comme moi au burkina faso au mali
et bien d'autres et dans bien d'autres
endroits
cette situation est extrêmement grave
car c'est le terreau qui nourrit
d'effervescence radical terroriste aussi
sur le plan politique les gouvernements
des états du bia elle du sahel doivent
affronter une situation extrêmement
complexe
les écoles doivent réouvrir pour
affaiblir et faire disparaître les
groupes armés terroristes
il faut agir à tous les niveaux
l'opération back barkan ne serait à elle
seule résoudre le phénomène terroriste
au sahel
elle est une condition nécessaire à
l'émergence de solutions politiques
si la zone passée sous le contrôle des
terroristes comme ce fut le cas en
afghanistan où le vent le risque serait
grand de voir la violence exportés
contre nos populations ne saurions alors
tu sens et d'intervenir dans des
conditions encore plus dégradée comme
nous l'avons fait en contre les taliban
ou contre l'état islamique
en somme l'action militaire n'empêche
pas la défaite
la victoire demeure entre les mains des
responsables politiques locaux
rien cependant ne permet de dire quand
de telles solutions pourront être
trouvées la france doit donc s'attendre
à ce que son intervention dans la dans
la région dur et nous devons nous y
préparer
dans ces conditions il convient de
vendre notre effort soutenable il faudra
continuer à chercher des soutiens
concrets à l'action que nous menons pour
que nous ne soyons pas seuls à supporter
les coûts de cette opération qui sert
les intérêts de tout le continent
européen
nous pouvons réduire notre effectif que
dans la mesure où de nouveaux
contingents européens prennent la relève
l'europe doit prendre en considération
cette dimension soit par une
mutualisation des coûts soit par une
contribution accrue à l'aide au
développement des pays du sahel cas
covenants veut son ensemble lutter
contre la misère
reste aussi le grand défi à relever
merci votre attention
merci mon cher collègue mais donner
maintenant la parole au président
guillaume vont tard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
vous avez la parole
présidant la dame la ministre monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission depuis la provocation en 2013
de l'opération serval devenu barkan le
parlement est muet il a parlé débat
budgétaire aucune discussion stratégique
n'est possible son rôle est réduit à
néant
l'esprit de l'article 35 de notre
constitution c'était inouï depuis bien
longtemps
aussi je me félicite de l'organisation
de ce débat
à la demande de notre commission même
s'il engage nullement le gouvernement il
a pourtant beaucoup à dire et à proposer
sept ans après le début de l'opération
barkan le bilan de l'engagement français
nous laisse perplexe il y a un an lors
du sommet de pau le président de la
république annoncé une montée en
puissance de l'opération notamment par
l'envoi d'un renfort de 600 hommes
le coût financier de l'opération lui
aussi s'est accrue nous sommes passés de
500 vies mais 520 millions d'euros en
2014 à environ un milliard d'euros en
2020 mais pour quel résultat
certes l'opération barkan en juin des
6es tactique comme les opérations
bourrasques et éclipse mais nous
rapproche si les objectifs de la france
et de ses partenaires les armées locales
sont elles en capacité de circonscrire
la menace terroriste
les états du sahel ont-ils rétabli leur
autorité et et ganges et est engagé par
dont un processus de réconciliation si
telles sont nos objectifs nous en sommes
encore loin
en effet il est clair que la
neutralisation d'individus deux auvents
ne fera pas disparaître le terrorisme
sur le long terme
l'hybridation des groupes armés avec le
tissu local et la montée des conflits
communautaires sont nourris par les
tensions systémique au pire au premier
rang desquels le changement climatique
la désertification mais sécheresse qui
décime le cheptel et assèche les points
d'eau touche durement les éleveurs et
les populations la sécurité alimentaire
s'ajoutent aux violences quotidiennes et
permet aux groupes terroristes de
proliférer face à ce bilan les
insuffisances de l'intervention
militaire deviennent évidentes
or ces assistants sont un coût humain
qui n'est plus possible de négliger tout
d'abord des pertes parmi l'armée
française se sont à ce jour 55 morts
français que nous déplorons au sahel
depuis 2013
les derniers le brigadier loïc risser et
le sergent yves honorine et est tombé au
mois de janvier 2021
je leur rends ici ainsi qu'à leurs
familles un hommage appuyé
mais c'est aussi la population civile
locale qui est la première victime de
ces conflits les pertes suivie ne se
conclue en centaines mais en milliers
sans parler des millions de personnes
déplacées et réfugiées dans un tel
contexte les circonstances de la frappe
opéré le 13 janvier près de bounty au
mali qui aurait potentiellement toucher
des civils doivent impérativement être
éclairé cette transparence est
nécessaire car une intervention qui ne
seraient plus soutenus par la population
locale perdrait sa légitimité
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la veille du
sommet de djamena où se réuniront de
nouveau le président de la république et
ses homologues du sahel pour un bilan
d'étape
ce bilan devrait un tournant car
l'enlisement qui devait être à tout prix
éviter sambre est déjà une réalité
à cet effet il me semble important de
rappeler plusieurs éléments la solution
militaire ne remplacera jamais la
solution politique dans un contexte de
démocratie fragiliser voire absente
depuis le coup d'état d'août 2020 il
faut en priorité appuyer les transitions
démocrate démocratique et redonner un
souffle à l'accord d'alger pour la paix
et la réconciliation au mali à ce jour
malgré l'activisme affichée par
l'algérie à la fin de l'été sa mise en
oeuvre reste laborieuse les états et
organisations médiateur avec en tête
l'algérie la france et l'onu doivent
donner ensemble une nouvelle impulsion à
l'accord d'autre part le tabou des
pourparlers avec certaines des
organisations armées doit être débattu
les négociations poursuivis par
certaines personnalités maliennes avec
ces groupes sont déjà une réalité et
doivent être accompagnés par la france
lorsque leurs revendications politiques
ou territoriales ne sont pas
incompatibles avec nos exigences
à cet effet la france doit soutenir
l'évolution d'un cadre politique clair
et légitime
ensuite si la france décide un
désengagement progressif
il doit s'accompagner d'une
participation européenne accrue est
garanti par un renforcement du g5
malgré le lancement de la taxe force
takouba d'année dernière la
participation de nos partenaires
européens resteront limitées
les contingents estonien tchèque et
suédois intégré à l'opération ne
représente pas une capacité
supplémentaire décisive
or au vu de la responsabilité que porte
nos voisins européens sur l'intervention
au sahel
une participation plus importante sur le
volet développement serait entièrement
justifiée pour conclure il me semble que
la solution politique que nous appelons
de nos voeux ne saurait exister sans un
renforcement considérable de l'aide
publique au développement
nous nous en reviendrons sur ce point
durant le débat
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole est maintenant au
président bruno retailleau pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre cheikh président
christian combes ans que je voudrais à
mon tour remercié puisque ça a déjà été
dit cet anneau cette initiative que nous
devons ce débat un débat qui tombe bien
qui tombe à pic
à quelques jours du sommet de djamena
qui va réunir nos partenaires du g5
sahel et dans un contexte où il faut
bien le dire
notre intervention sur tous ces
modalités sont de plus en plus
questionné merci donc à christian cambon
c'est donc l'occasion pour nous à la
fois d'adressé au gouvernement un
message mais au nom de mon groupe tout
particulièrement je voudrais aussi
rendre un hommage appuyé à nos armées
françaises qui font la fierté là bas
très loin d'ici
de toute la nation mais qui font aussi
l'admiration mes chers collègues d'une
très grande partie des armées du monde
parce que ce qu'accomplit l'armée
française au sahel dans des conditions
si difficiles sur un territoire aussi
vaste avec des moyens somme toute
limitée très peu d'armes et très peu
d'armes et dans le monde en serait
capable et je veux leur dire ceci jamais
dicton n'a été aussi faut jamais dicton
populaire n'a été aussi faux loin des
yeux loin du coeur
non les français savent que nos soldats
là-bas lutte contre l'islamisme le
terrorisme
là bas comme chez nous c'est le même
combat
c'est un combat sans cesse recommencé
pour la paix pour la liberté et pour la
vie bien évidemment et nous avons à
l'esprit leur courage qui est une vertu
suprême comme le disait aristote puisque
c'est elle qui permet toutes les autres
nous avons aussi à l'esprit leur
engagement leur engagement au nom d'un
idéal français à travers le don de soi
si différent de cette obsession de soi
si contemporaine
non nos cinquante cinq soldats auxquels
je veux rendre aussi hommage ne sont pas
morts pour
bien nous avons connue et nous
connaîtrons encore des succès militaires
est ce que je veux dire c'est que sans
l'intervention de la france à travers
ses différentes prisons de république à
travers ses différents gouvernements
sans cette intervention en réalité que
se serait-il passé nous aurions là bas
sans doute un sanctuaire islamistes nous
aurions là bas un nouveau califat un
nouveau proto état au coeur du sel est
aux portes du maghreb c'est à dire à la
frontière sud de l'europe à la frontière
sud de la france mais pour autant
puisque barkan est un succès militaire
pour autant ça doit malgré tout nous
ouvrir des perspectives pour discuter de
cet engagement
nous savons très très bien madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre que et les
dernières décennies nous l'ont appris
c'est une leçon de ces dernières années
il n'y a pas de succès militaires qui
permettent de déboucher sur une paix
durable sans que ses succès soit relayé
soit prolongée par des succès
diplomatiques des succès politiques
c'est d'ailleurs madame liste que vous
avez déclaré à la commission lorsque
vous avez dit et je reprends vos mots il
faut désormais transformer les gains
ecti tactique en progrès je crois
politiques et sociaux alors à quelles
conditions
pouvons-nous à conduire cette
transformation nous avons aussi entendu
à brest pour les re veut les voeux aux
armées le président de république qu'à
utiliser une expression il a dit il
faudra sans doute ajuster notre effort
comme si peut-être mais je me trompe et
vous me démentir et sans doute comme
s'il s'agissait de revenir aux effectifs
d'avant le sommet de pau si c'est cela
nous voulons vous dire que ce serait le
statu quo et nous pensons que ni le
retrait net une option parce que le
retrait ruinerait tous nos efforts
rentrer est inutile la mort de nos
soldats mais ni le statu quo ne saurait
tenir lieu d'une stratégie parce que ce
statu quo risquerait de nous emmener
dans un embourbement alors quelles sont
précisément les conditions les pistes en
tout cas pour un engagement réussi
et pour non seulement des succès
militaires mais aussi des succès
politiques d'abord le dispositif
militaire je ne veux pas reprendre ce
qu'a dit très bien christian cambon tout
à l'heure il faudra s'adapter en
permanence se concentrer sur les forces
spéciales aéroportées évidemment nos
forces qui risquent lorsqu'elles sont à
terre un certain nombre de bombes qui
font du mal il faut sécuriser bien sûr
sécurisé avec un blindage approprié le
transport de nos troupes
la deuxième piste c'est la piste qui
demandera plus efforts sans doute plus
d'engagements à nos partenaires à
commencer par les partenaires européens
certes takuma est une avancée mais elle
est insuffisant et je pense que la
perspective la plus prometteuse
la perspective sans doute la plus
immédiate concernant les partenaires
européens c'est le renforcement de la
mutualisation c'est le renforcement de
nos contributions de leur contribution à
notre effort pour la sécurité globale
ça me paraît capital il y a et il reste
bien sûr le g5 celles qui paient le prix
du sang un très lourd tribut
je pense que on doit les accompagner
mais ils doivent renforcer leurs
engagements
je sers le disant que c'est plus facile
à dire que affaire évidemment et puis à
la troisième piste sur lequel je veux
insister et les capitales je pense que
la combinaison de notre effort de
sécurité vis-à-vis de notre effort de
coopération est mal calibré si je suis
les chiffres du président cambon chaque
jour l'opération nous coûte 2 millions
chaque jour
ce que nous mettons en coopération ces
deux cent mille euros c'est insuffisant
la france seule ne peut pas tout ce que
je propose précisément c'est de faire
plus contribué l'europe l'europe
mes chers collègues est le premier
contributeur mondial au soutien
humanitaire
elle doit pouvoir mieux nous aider bien
évidemment de même que l'afd
donc permettez moi de vous dire parfois
la logique nous dépasse et nous aurions
et nous aimerions d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus de transparence
mais dans cette combinaison entre
l'effort
de sécurité et entre l'effort de
coopération c'est capital parce que dans
ces zones désertiques une école un
dispensaire l'accès à l'eau font
tellement plus que boutou beaucoup
d'autres actions c'est capital et pour
terminer
évidemment il ne peut pas y avoir de
reconstruction sans réconciliation il
faudra exiger du mali qu'il applique les
accords d'alger il faudra sans doute que
l'algérie elle-même rentrer dans ce jeu
pour garantir justement ces accords de
même qui fera encourager le dialogue
entre le nord et le sud entre le peuple
peuple et le peuple dogon voilà madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre nos
soldats au sahel savent quelle est leur
devoir leur devoir c'est servir la
mission à nous désormais de leur
indiquer quel est le sens de leur combat
quel est notre vision servi par quelle
stratégie
bien évidemment c'est ce que nous
attendons de vous sachez que mon groupe
assumera toujours ceux de voir quelles
que soient nos options politiques nous
considérons que dès lors qu'il s'agit de
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation de nos
armées nous serons madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre toujours à vos
côtés et aux côtés de l'armée française
merci monsieur le président or
je vais donner la parole maintenant aux
milices de l'europe et les affaires
étrangères monsieur jean yves le drian
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président madame la ministre
mesdames les sénatrices mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs j'ai pensée
particulière à cet instant à l'égard de
jean marie bockel comme beaucoup d'entre
vous monsieur le président quand bon ça
fait huit ans que nous avons pour ma
part sous des responsabilités
différentes un dialogue au sein de la
commission des affaires étrangères la
défense et des forces armées du sénat
avec vous même un dialogue franc un
dialogue confiant un dialogue exigeant
sur la situation au sahel
parfois même toutes les semaines c'était
le cas au début un prêt plus tôt tous
les mois mais j'ai tenu
je le dis à monsieur gontard à être
présents régulièrement pour répondre aux
questions de la commission des affaires
étrangères
quand tout le monde peut en témoigner
parce que cet engagement nécessite une
transparence la plus totale sur nous
avancer nos recrues nos interrogations
je crois que je n'ai pour ma part et
madame paris n'ont plus jamais manqué ce
rendez vous est donc je me réjouis
monsieur le président quand vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs que ce dialogue se poursuivre
aujourd'hui en séance plénière parce que
j'estime aussi que au delà de la
représentation nationale nos concitoyens
doivent savoir ce que nous faisons c'est
lé pourquoi nous le faisons avec qui
nous le faisons et sur quelle stratégie
nous nous orientons et c'est d'autant
plus important maintenant qu'on assiste
depuis plusieurs mois à une montée très
préoccupante des manipulations de
l'information au sahel
et des manipulations de l'information à
propos du sel et s'ils sont d'abord
destinés à alimenter sur place un
sentiment anti français que certains
acteurs tentent d'instrumentaliser à des
femmes politiques
elles peuvent risquer aussi de venir
brouiller la perception de notre action
ici même en france et donc notre
responsabilité commune mais je l' ai
senti dans toutes les interventions et
de ne pas laisser ce piège se refermer
sur l'opinion publique française qui
méritent de pouvoir juger à partir des
faits donc ce débat est bienvenue ce
débat je les bien notées portes au
premier chef sur le bilan et les
perspectives de barkan mais de mon point
de vue et si je suis ici aux côtés de la
ministre des armées c'est que vous
partagez aussi ce constat on ne saurait
traiter ces questions sans prendre en
compte l'ensemble de l' architecture
dans laquelle cette opération s'insère
désormais est que nous avons patiemment
bâti au fil des années avec nos
partenaires sahélien européens et
internationaux
la mise en place du g5 sahel en 2014 la
mise en place de sa force conjointe en
la mise en place de l'alliance elle la
même année le lancement du partenariat
pour la sécurité et la stabilité au
celle que l'on appelle parfois p3s en
2019 et enfin la création de la
coalition pour le sahel l'an dernier
sont à cet égard
autant de jalons décisifs dans un double
mouvement d'internationalisation de la
lutte contre la menace terroriste au
sahel et de définition d'un cadre global
et intégré pour apporter à cette crise
complexe non seulement les réponses du
court terme celle de l'action militaire
et de la stabilisation mais aussi les
réponses du temps long celle de la
négociation politique est celle du
développement double mouvement qui
montre que depuis huit ans les lignes en
considérablement bouger au sahel en
dépit des polémiques sur un enlisement
français dans cette région polémique qui
elles n'avancent guère dire cela
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs ce n'est pas nier l'importance
ni et le sens de l'engagement de nos
soldats au sel c'est évidemment rien
retrancher à la valeur du sacrifice de
celles et ceux qui sont tombés que vous
avez souligné les uns et les autres
c'est au contraire affirmé que barkan a
été le socle sur lequel se basent ce
dispositif a pu se construire et qu'ils
jouent encore que barkan joue encore ce
rôle de socle aujourd'hui bien que la
charge soit mieux distribuer entre nous
et nos partenaires et permettez-moi de
pointe et trois malentendu qui planent
encore trop souvent sur les discussions
que nous pouvons avoir sur le sel et
dont j'espère que nous saurons nous le
garder aujourd'hui gelée constaté en
vous écoutant le premier de ces
malentendus tient une forme d'amnésie
qui pourrait conduire à penser si vous
me permettez l'expression que ce qui se
passe au sahel n'est pas notre affaire
et je veux rappeler avec d'autres qu'ils
l'ont fait tout à l'heure présent qu'on
bon j'en acte défini sénateur guérini
je veux rappeler les raisons des ide en
retail haut de notre engagement
d'abord dans le cadre de l'opération
serval puis dans le cadre de l'opération
barkan
je rappelle mais vous le savez en 2012
le mali se trouvait au bord de
l'effondrement
effondrement politique parce qu'il y
avait eu un coup d'état de capitaine
sanogo qui a renversé le régime de
toumani touré avant que le président
transitoire traoré ne se voit confier
une prévision une présidence provisoire
effondrement politique effondrement
sécuritaire puisque une alliance de
groupes terroristes affiliés à al qaïda
occupait le nord du pays jusqu'à
tombouctou où il avait entrepris de
soumettre la population locale à la
charia il était en train de le faire et
quelle il avait entrepris de détruire
des mausolées classée au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco et ils se
préparaient à prendre d'assaut la
capitale du mali bamako
cet effondrement
aurait été une véritable catastrophe non
seulement pour la population malienne
qui se seraient vus condamnés à vivre
sur la loi d'un califat islamique
implacable mais également pour nous en
france et en europe puisque ce khalifa
aurait pu servir de sanctuaire aux
jihadistes un sanctuaire où attirer des
combattants en provenance de l'étranger
à sanctuaires d'où projeté des attaques
vers l'étranger je vous rappelle que un
an et demi plus tard au levant d'autres
djihadistes mais toujours dans la même
obédience proclamait l'instauration d'un
proto état totalitaire le pseudo khalifa
de dèche
nous avons donc eu raison chacun l'a
souligné de prendre cette menace très au
sérieux nous avons eu raison d'agir très
vite en lançant l'opération serval dès
janvier 2013 à la demande des autorités
maliennes du président traoré qui était
à l'époque le président de transition
cette opération était réussi elle a
porté un coup d'arrêt à la progression
des jihadistes vers le sud a libéré les
régions d'une heure sur le plan
politique cette opération a aussi permis
le retour d'un processus démocratique
parce qu'il y a eu l'élection du
président de la république du mali qui
s'est fait dans de bonnes conditions
mais parce qu'ils avaient été défaits au
mali nos adversaires sont passés d'une
stratégie d'implantation locale qui
seraient tentés d'appeler une stratégie
d'occupation territoriales à une
stratégie de déstabilisation régionale
[Musique]